hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live seit Monaten berichten wir immer
wieder über die heftigen Kämpfe in der
ukrainischen Stadt bachmut heute
berichtet die Söldnergruppe Wagner sie
hätte die Stadt erobert die ukrainische
Armee die sagt aber sie halte die Stadt
weiter sind widersprüchliche Aussagen
und es ist vor allem auch eine Schlacht
die als die längste seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffs Krieges gilt und die
unfassbar viele Ressourcen verbraucht
hat Russland stehe dabei laut vieler
Experten schlechter da als erwartet die
Ukraine kommt parallel auch heute wieder
Unterstützung aus dem Westen zugesichert
es gibt eine Meldung Polen verkündet vor
wenigen Stunden dass die ersten
Kampfjets mit 29 an die Ukraine
geliefert worden sein und außerdem auch
heute noch das hier ein Politiker Besuch
aus Deutschland dennoch einmal zeigen
soll wir stehen an der Seite der Ukraine
denn nun ist auch Vizekanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck zum ersten
Mal seit Kriegsbeginn in die Ukraine
gereist nach Kiew mit einer kleinen
Wirtschaftsdelegation es geht bei dem
Besuch vor allem um Zusammenarbeit im
Wirtschaftsbereich aber auch das sagte
Habeck er wolle ein klares Zeichen an
die Ukraine setzen dass man an einen
ukrainischen Sieg Glaube und die Ukraine
wieder aufgebaut werden so Habeck die
wahrscheinlich ein nahe Sieg der Ukraine
ist und ob die Schlacht um Bach Mut
Russland eher schadet als nützt das
wollen wir heute besprechen wir sehen
ihn schon im Hintergrund Militärexperte
Markus Keup ist bei uns hallo schönen
guten Tag
hallo guten Abend wir stellen also heute
die Frage das habt ihr auf dem stunnel
auch gesehen Putins Offensive
gescheitert ihr könnt natürlich Fragen
stellen per Mail oder direkt im Stream
an Herrn Kolb und wir versuchen so viele
wie möglich davon ich versuche sie einen
kurz zu stellen und er sie natürlich für
euch zu beantworten Herr Kolb die erste
ich habe es angesprochen da sind also
zwei widersprüchliche Aussagen jetzt ähm
vermeldet zum einen eben die Aussage der
Söldner sie hätten wachmut ist rechtlich
eingenommen so hieß es bei telegram und
die Ukraine wiederum sagt sie halten
weiter stand was stimmt da
ja es wird schon fast zum Running Gag
das pregotion jetzt bald jeden Tag die
endgültige Einnahme von bachmut
verkündet also was tatsächlich passiert
ist ist Wagner ist wieder ein paar Meter
vorgerückt in der eigentlichen
stadtbachmut und hat offenbar das
Gebäude der Zivilverwaltung von bachmut
eingenommen das natürlich wie alle
anderen Gebäude nur noch Ruine ist und
hat das also so verkauft quasi weil das
der Sitz der Zivilverwaltung jetzt
rechtlich von ihm erobert worden also
wie das in seinem krankenhirn sich da
zusammen rein das weiß ich nicht die
militärische Realität ist jedenfalls
eine andere und die sieht so aus dass
man den russischen Vormarsch
mittlerweile in Metern messen kann er
hat sich seit dem 21 märz jeden Tag ein
bisschen mehr verlangsamt und ist jetzt
eigentlich in offenen Häuser Kampf
übergegangen und da sehen sie eben dass
die eigentliche Idee der wagnertruppe
gescheitert ist die wollte nämlich nach
Mut nördlich und südlich umfassen und
damit quasi im Rücken der ukrainischen
Verteidiger einen Ring schließen und
also damit einen klassischen Kessel
eigentlich entstehen lassen nun hat die
Ukraine aber Entlastungsangriffe
durchgeführt sowohl an der nördlichen
wie auch an der südlichen Flanke und das
hat nun dazu geführt dass Wagner an
diesen beiden Flanken nicht weiterkommt
und nun ragt bachmut sowie ein Keil oder
wie ein Dorn in die russische Front
hinein und dann sagen sich die Wagner
Leute na gut wenn wir an den Flanken
nicht weiterkommen dann machen wir es
jetzt eben frontal das heißt also wir
rücken jetzt Straße für Straße in der
Stadtbach Mode von Osten nach Westen
durch so lange bis wir dann alles
erobert haben das bedeutet natürlich
dass die enormen Verluste die sie bisher
in Kauf genommen haben noch mal
ansteigen werden dem Häuserkampf ist so
ziemlich das blutigste und das
abnutzungsintensivste was sie haben
können als angreifen
gesehen in einer Grafik die wir parallel
zum Gespräch eingeblendet haben wie sich
also die Kämpfe im letzten Jahr
verändert haben wir schauen jetzt auch
erstmal gemeinsam in einen Bericht also
die Zusammenfassung der
Ereignisse da Umbach Mut einen Bericht
von Paula Kolberg
seit vielen Monaten ist bachmut im Osten
der Ukraine hart umkämpft am Sonntag
erklärte der Chef der russischen seltene
Gruppe wagnerin man habe bachmut erobert
im rechtlichen Sinne ist bachmut
eingenommen worden die Kommandeure der
Einheiten die das Rathaus und das
gesamte Zentrum eingenommen haben werden
diese Flagge aufstellen
die es dementierte die Ukraine heute und
veröffentlichte dieses Video es soll
ukrainische Soldaten zeigen die
weiterhin die Stadt verteidigen dabei
braucht Russland dringend Erfolge die
Verluste sind bei minimalen
geländegewinnen sehr hoch das britische
Verteidigungsministerium meldet 200.000
gefallene russische Soldaten seit
Kriegsbeginn auch die Panzer scheinen
Russland auszugehen nach
us-informationen hat die Ukraine bereits
sehr viele russische Fahrzeuge zerstört
insgesamt 200.000 200.000 gefallene
Soldaten das haben wir gerade gehört und
auch eben viele Experten die sagen also
bei dieser Schlacht hat Russland eher
verloren würden Sie sagen also wirklich
jetzt schon zu viel verloren kann man
das schon so sagen
also wenn wir die Verlustquote an
schweren Systemen und schweren
Fahrzeugen anschauen dann haben wir
nämlich bald ein Jubiläum und ich denke
das sagt mehr als das ein langer
Kommentar nämlich 10.000 10.000 schwere
Waffensysteme und schwere Fahrzeuge also
inklusive Panzer hat Russland bald
verloren jedenfalls nach der noch
konservativen Zählung der
origex-liste und wenn Sie jetzt das mal
Herunterrechnen auf die Tage des
Kriegsverlaufs dann ist es eine
abnutzungsrate die Russland schlichtweg
nicht durchhalten kann das heißt es ist
eigentlich nur eine Frage der Zeit bis
in die Reserven ausgehen und was man
auch sehen muss ist die Medien
konzentrieren sich natürlich ganz extrem
auf bachmut es ist so ein bisschen
näheren Effekt aber man muss ja schauen
die russische Winteroffensive wenn man
sie so nennen will die fand ja nicht nur
in bachmut statt die fand eigentlich an
fünf verschiedenen konzentrierten Orten
statt also zum Beispiel auch im Raum
Trainer und auf die jewka in Marinka in
vuleda wo Russland alleine in zwei Tagen
130 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge verloren hat
also wenn Sie den gesamten frontbogen
angucken und das sind nur etwa 120 km
der gesamtfront von 1200 dann ist das
einfach ein Desaster also das hat mit
militärischer Logik eigentlich nichts
mehr zu tun sondern das ist ein ein
massives hin Opfern von Reserven sowohl
was Material als auch Menschen angeht
für minimale Fortschritte sie haben das
Material angesprochen da gibt's bei uns
eine Frage im Stream bei Youtube von
User oder Userin Hip Hop Guru er oder
sie fragt sich fragt mich bei all den
Bildern die man von russischen Equipment
meistens so sieht wo eigentlich all die
wirklich modernen Sachen sind
ja das frage ich mich auch häufig ich
habe ironischerweise 2014 als der Krieg
ja eigentlich losging mit mit der
Donders Invasion habe ich einen Artikel
geschrieben über den russischen armata
t-14 und habe gesagt ne also wir wissen
ja was da kommt und passt auf ne weil
der ist schon sehr mächtig im Kampf
fähig aber so wie sich bisher zeigt
scheint dir doch eher ein Phantom zu
sein also wir haben bisher diese
Exemplare gesehen auch Paraden aber im
Kampfraum bisher noch nicht das
modernste was wir bisher gesehen haben
ist der t9s eine Version die eigentlich
für den Export bestimmt ist und auch die
sind bereits abgeschossen worden genau
wie die T 80 DT 72 und so weiter also
man kann eigentlich sagen technologisch
gesehen eskaliert Russland nach unten äh
jetzt haben sie T64 mobilisiert und auch
T55 und es gibt bereits Sport im Netz
was kommt als nächstes T34 und danach
Pferde ähm also die die Frage ist völlig
berechtigt und ich denke es ist findet
hier wirklich eine große die zauberung
der russischen armeestadt viele
Analysten ich übrigens auch haben sich
in der Vergangenheit einfach so ein
bisschen beeindrucken lassen von Zahlen
die die Russen gemeldet haben und
Systeme die sie vorgeführt haben auf
Paraden und und
gegenüber feindlichen
Nachrichtendiensten aber in Wirklichkeit
scheint da doch relativ wenig dahinter
zu stecken Sie das habe ich gelesen in
dem Interview in der NZZ sie sind sehr
optimistisch was den Ausgang des Krieges
für die Ukraine anbelangt sie nennen
sogar ein Zeitfenster an dem der Krieg
beendet sein soll sie haben also gesagt
in diesem Interview im Oktober wird die
Ukraine Russland besiegen wie kommen Sie
darauf
ja das hängt einfach mit der
abnutzungsrate der schweren Systeme
zusammen also in diesem Wind Interview
habe ich das am Beispiel der Panzer mal
vorgerechnet wie lange reicht die
Konsensschätzung über
russlandseinsatzfähige Panzer noch bis
sie endgültig alle weg sind und die
ähnliche Rechnung können sie für andere
schwere Fahrzeuge also für Arbeit fahre
irgendwie
kurz aufmachen ich entschuldige mich ein
bisschen für das Englisch wir fahren
jetzt gerade die die deutschen
Fachbegriffe nicht ein ähm aber wenn Sie
wenn Sie schauen mit welcher
unglaublichen rate diese Reserven
abschmelzen dann kommen sie sehr bald an
einen Punkt wo Russland einfach nicht
mehr in der Lage ist überhaupt noch
Operationen zu führen das heißt das
einzige was sie dann tun können ist sich
einzugraben das ist aber keine gute Idee
weil gegenüber steht ein anderes
Technologie denn die Ukraine geht jetzt
im Laufe des früheren Sommer eben über
von alter sowjetischer Technologie auf
westliche Technologie also insbesondere
auf westliche Kampfpanzer und
verlässliche infanteriefahrzeuge wie zum
Beispiel den Bradley oder den Marder und
das darf man auf keinen Fall
unterschätzen diesen Effekt ist her
kämpft in diesem Krieg sowjetmaterial
gegen sowjetmaterial aber das wird sich
fundamental ändern und
sobald die ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive losgeht also ich
rechne so etwa Mitte April damit da wird
man diesen technologieeffekt dann
deutlich sehen und das wird dann zu
einer noch größeren Verlustrate der
Russen führen wenn Sie das so ein
bisschen zusammen sich überlegen wozu
führt das eigentlich in der in der
gefechtsführung dann dann ist eigentlich
gar kein anderer Ausgang denkbar ich
denke Europa ist einfach im Moment so
sehr durchsäugt von der russischen
Propaganda das viele ist schwierig
finden das zu glauben und deswegen sage
ich immer sie müssen das nicht glauben
das ist keine Frage des Glaubens sie
müssen einfach die Zahlen sich angucken
und die abnutzungsrate betrachten und
dann kommen sie eigentlich schon zu
belastbaren Schlussfolgerungen ich bin
übrigens wie immer von
Rollen und und anderen Leuten scharf
angegriffen worden dass ich das gesagt
habe aber ich möchte an der Stelle auch
sagen ich bin ja längst nicht der
einzige der das sagt Kellog sagt das
gleiche patrius sagt das gleiche Ben
Hodge ist auch also es ist nicht so dass
ich jetzt ein Exot wäre mit dieser
Meinung sondern es gibt durchaus ein
Konsens unter westlichen
militäranalysten oder zumindest unter
solchen die den Namen verdienen ich
möchte gerne aber eine Frage von mir
dazu mit einer user-frage kombinieren
weil sie haben jetzt eben angesprochen
also anhand von Zahlen über Abnutzung
kommen Sie zu dieser Aussage also woher
kommen sie diese woher bekommen Sie die
Zahlen woher nehmen sie die und User ist
ein Eckert möchte wissen wenn Herr Kolb
von Reserven spricht von welchem
Zeitraum ist da die Rede Monate Jahre
und was wird den Russen zuerst ausgehen
Material Munition oder Menschen
also zu der Konsensschätzung der können
Sie die schwedische verteidigungsagentur
fui heißt die mit Abkürzung anschauen da
gibt es 2019 gibt es eine wunderbare
Studie zur Kampfkraft der russischen
okay sie können ebenso das Institut für
stratec studies das iiss in London
angucken das bringt jedes Jahr der
militarlands raus und auch die kommen
auf eine etwa gleiche Konsensschätzung
also von ungefähr 2900 einsatzfähigen
System das ist für den Bestand und für
die Abnutzung nehme ich den orix-block
den kennen einige User vielleicht man
muss dazu sagen dieser Blog ist
wahrscheinlich noch konservativ weil er
eben nur das zählt an russischen
Verlusten was tatsächlich ein Bild oder
Video lokalisiert ist erzählt übrigens
auch die ukrainischen Verluste auch das
empfehle ich den Usern machen Sie
einfach mal direkten Vergleich oder
basteln sie sich selber ein kleines
Excel Charts und schauen Sie mal wie die
russischen Verluste sich verhalten im
Vergleich zu den ukrainischen und das
gibt ihnen ein recht gutes Bild welche
Mengen welche Massen an Material da
drauf gehen bei der russischen Operation
zur letzten Frage ich denke Russland
werden als erstes die schweren Systeme
ausgehen also insbesondere Kampfpanzer
modernere Art
man muss aber auch sehen dass es ähm
Systeme gibt über die im Moment wenig
gesprochen wird insbesondere gegnerische
Radar Aufklärung gegen artiller
Systeme zur elektronischen Krieg Führung
die die Ukraine in den letzten Wochen
ebenfalls sehr erfolgreich
herausgenommen hat und auch das ähm
wirkt sich schädlich aus auf die
Möglichkeit der Russen überhaupt noch
offensiven
und wenn wir aber jetzt noch mal über
die Reserven sprechen also eine Reserve
die Russland haben könnte könnte ja auch
mehr Menschen sein es gibt also Berichte
darüber dass Russland 400.000 neue
Soldaten rekrutieren möchte das ist dann
auch nichts was sie von dieser Aussage
abbringen könnte weil 400.000 neue
Soldaten das könnte ja schon auch was
verändern oder ja das erinnert mich so
an diese propagandaerzählung die wir im
Februar hatten demnächst brechen 700.000
Mann durch die Dialog russischen Wälder
und Sümpfe und nehmen die Ukraine von
Norden allen hier also was sie zunächst
immer mal bedenken müssen ist russische
Ankündigungen und russische Realitäten
sind zwar völlig verschiedene Welten ich
weiß nicht warum das in Deutschland
immer so wörtlich interpretiert wird was
die Russen sagen also sie müssen wenn
ein russischer Funktionär oder Politiker
sich äußert davon ausgehen dass jedes
Wort dass er sagt gelogen ist und sofern
es nicht gelogen ist ist es mindestens
um 200% übertrieben
wenn sie selbst an diese 400.000 jetzt
mal glauben möchten also nehmen wir mal
an das sei real auch dann dürfen sie
nicht Einsatzwert und einfach Anzahl
verwechseln also nur die Tatsache dass
sie irgendwelche armen Menschen in
diesen Fleischwolf da hineinwerfen an
der Front heißt es noch lange nicht dass
die Kampfkraft entfalten das haben sie
insbesondere in buleta gesehen also
diese diese dilettantische Art wie die
Leute in den Fahrzeugen operieren und
die Fahrzeuge teilweise in offenem
Minenfelder hineinfahren das sagt Ihnen
vor allem eines das nämlich die
eigentliche professionelle russische
Armee die vor der Invasion bestanden hat
also die Kontakte die also sprich
sozusagen Soldaten auf Zeit die die gut
ausgebildet waren die auch gut bezahlt
waren dass die größtenteils ausgefallen
sind und durch schlechter oder gar nicht
ausgebildete mobics ersetzt worden sind
das heißt es kommt eigentlich nicht auf
die Anzahl der Menschen an bei der
Operationsführung es kommt auf ihren
Ausbildungsstand und ihre Kampfkraft an
das gab es schon im zaristischen
Russland da gab es diesen zynischen
Begriff das treue Vieh also gemeint
waren damit vor allem die Bauern die man
in die Armee gepresst hat die jahrelang
dort zu bringen mussten und zum Beispiel
im Ersten Weltkrieg an der Westfront
geradezu massenhaft hin geopfert wurden
von der zaristischen Armee ähm also sie
sehen es gibt gewisse Kontinuitäten in
der russischen Geschichte die ändern
sich nie und äh von von daher muss man
das mit großer Vorsicht betrachten wenn
solche Propaganda Zahlen im Raum
herumgeistern ich sage immer mich
interessieren nicht diese
Verlautbarungen sondern ich schaue mir
an was tatsächlich im Kampfraum passiert
und das ist halt ein völlig anderes Bild
es gibt auch Fragen bzw vielleicht
sorgen Gedanken dazu im Stream was denn
ist oder was denn wäre wenn Russland
also auch von außen von anderen Mächten
unterstützt würde so fragt sich renegate
MTB bei youtube ist es denn sowas ist es
denn so unwahrscheinlich dass China
Zeitner Waffensysteme an Russland
liefert die das Blatt in der Ukraine
wenden könnten
ja ich denke das ist das mehrere und
Gründen unwahrscheinliches interessant
ich habe gerade in dieser Sendung ZDF
heute live das ist schon ein paar Monate
her da habe ich mir das mal
durchgerechnet und zwar damals hat man
spekuliert könnte Nordkorea denn nicht
Russland unterstützen mit
Artilleriegranaten dann habe ich das mal
durchgerechnet wie viel Güterzüge
bräuchten sie und was würde der wiegen
und ich kam dann bei der damaligen
feuerfrequenz von 50.000 Artillerie
Granaten pro Tag auf ungefähr einen
Güterzug von 1600 Tonnen pro Tag jeden
Tag und der fährt dann auf der Transit
9000 km bis an die Front sofern er nicht
vorher von den Ukrainern rausgenommen
wird also nehmen wir an der das wäre
tatsächlich so und es wäre jetzt nicht
Nordkorea sondern China das könnte nicht
unentdeckt bleiben das würde man sofort
entdecken und dann kommt natürlich das
Thema sekundäre Sanktionen und vor
nichts haben die Chinesen mehr Angst als
vor sekundär und Sanktion das heißt also
dass der besten ähnlich harte
Handelsbeschränkungen aufgelegt die
gegenüber Russland weil zwei Drittel
chinesischen Exporte gehen in den Westen
und gerade mal zwei Prozent nach
Russland also sprich wenn ich jetzt
China bin dann Kette ich mich sicherlich
nicht an das untergehende Putin Regime
sondern dann bin ich doch eher
pragmatisch orientiert und es gibt
übrigens noch einen anderen Grund wenn
sie mal die Geschichte des fernen Ostens
anschauen dann werden Sie feststellen
dass viele Gebiete die wir heute
russisch nennen also vor allem die
Gebiete nördlich des Amur wo heute
Städte liegen wie Wladi Rostock
und da müssen sie zurück gucken in die
Geschichte der 1860er Jahre in die
sogenannten ungleichen Verträge die
damals des zaristische Russland im
kaiserlichen China aufgezwungen hat und
damals musste ich China diese Gebiete
abtreten an Russland das heißt also
insbesondere die Städte aber doch und
die sind noch nicht so lange Russisch
und es ist durchaus möglich dass China
sich da denken na ja wer weiß ob
Russland sich nicht intern die
stabilisiert und ob wir darüber noch mal
nachdenken sollten darüber spricht heute
kaum jemand über die Bereichen Verträge
des 19 Jahrhunderts aber ich möchte doch
beliebt machen dass die chinesische
Perspektive vor allem eine sehr sehr
realistische sehr sehr
handelsorientierte ist und auch eine
sehr sehr langfristige das heißt man
vergisst nicht so schnell was in der
Geschichte früher passiert ist und doch
wenn wir jetzt noch kurz bei der
Unterstützung möglicherweise eben für
Russland bleiben wenn man das dann so
nennen kann also es gibt ja auch oder
soll auch immer mehr seltener Gruppen
geben wie Wagner eben jetzt einfach Mut
die für Russland kämpfen also so soll
der russische Energiekonzern Gazprom ein
eigenes Militärunternehmen gegründet
haben und diese Truppe so heißt es soll
bereits in der Ostukraine kämpfen die
berechenbar ist das denn wenn man das
jetzt noch mit einem bezieht dass da
also noch mehrere söldnergruppen dazu
kommen könnten ja also ich sage mal
viele Menschen haben jetzt gemerkt dass
es private russische Militärunternehmen
und das sollte eine Gruppen gibt aber
besonders neu ist das nicht also die gab
es schon in der Nullerjahren das ist
wieder neu noch ist das irgendwie
besonders diese Privatarmee von Gazprom
die gibt es übrigens tatsächlich die
heißt stav Center und hat ihren Sitz in
Omsk die ist gerade erst gegründet
worden aber es gibt natürlich auch
andere es gibt Patriots also die
Privatarmee von von Schoigu die die
hassen natürlich Wagner und umgekehrt
also schonko und war und äh Pregarten
die mögen sich nicht äh und bekämpfen
sich natürlich politisch auch durch den
Ansatz ihrer Privatarmee aber es gibt
noch andere es gibt das lavonische kurz
z.B aus dem Wagner mal hervorgegangen
ist also neu ist das nicht und das jetzt
natürlich diese Akteure so ihre Chance
bittern und versuchen sich aufzustellen
das ist nicht unbedingt neu zum Beispiel
die User werden sich vielleicht erinnern
an Igor girken auch als bekannt der in
der 2014 Inversion eine Rolle gespielt
hat Entschuldigung
und der hat gerade gestern mit einigen
anderen zusammen den Club der wütenden
Patrioten gegründet heißt wirklich so
und noch beschränkt er sich auf
kriegs-propaganda aber ich halte es
nicht für unmöglich dass er vielleicht
auch auf die Idee kommt jetzt stelle ich
mir meine eigene Truppe zusammen und und
sorge für mein eigenes Wohl also es
entwickelt sich zunehmend so ein
bisschen Game of Thrones in diesem
ganzen Spiel wo eben die Akteure merken
ja die die die diese Macht des Putin
Regimes die beginnt und bisschen zu
bröckeln und das ist zeigen sich so
erste Risse an der Peripherie und immer
wenn das passiert in der russischen
Geschichte dann kommen Leute auf die
Idee dass der Chef möglicherweise nicht
mehr der Chef ist und beginnen dann die
Messer zu setzen und das kann für Putin
sehr schnell gefährlich werden
es gibt noch einige Fragen und
Kommentare die ich hier gerne noch
mitnehmen möchte vielleicht gehen wir
auch mal ein bisschen zu Kommentaren zu
unserem Stream also einmal schreibt Dirk
über Youtube bisher hatte Herr Kolb mit
sehr sehr vielem Recht schreibt er was
er im Verlauf des Krieges analysiert hat
ich hoffe sehr dass er auch mit dem
heutigen heutigen heute gesagt ein Recht
behalten wird danke für den Stream Doris
Ratgeber ist der kritischer bei Facebook
und schreibt wenn man diesen Experten
immer hört fragt man sich weshalb die
Ukraine noch nicht längst gewonnen hat
und wenn es Lügen geht das machen doch
alle also da die kritische Frage ja wenn
man das jetzt so hört wir haben auch
schon oft und viel natürlich gesprochen
über den Kriegsverlauf im letzten Jahr
da kann man vielleicht das Gefühl
bekommen so sieht's nicht schon längst
besser aus für die Ukraine also wieso
sagen sie erst Oktober
also zunächst mal ich kann nicht für
andere sprechen oder beurteilen
inwiefern sie lügen oder inwiefern sie
Propaganda betreiben ich möchte hier nur
klarstellen ich tue das nicht ich glaube
nicht dass es auf die expertenanzug auf
Basis dieser Fakten meine Meinung also
das das wollte ich mal grundsätzlich
loswerden ich habe außerdem meine Lage
Einschätzung laufen dem Kriegsverlauf
angepasst also sie können gerne meine
älteren Interviews mal anschauen z.B aus
dem Sommer 2022 da war ich noch nicht so
optimistisch und habe gesagt ähm die
Ukraine wird sich zwar erfolgreich gegen
die Invasion aber ob sie das gewinnen
kann dass es viel zu früh darüber zu
sprechen also zu einem Zeitpunkt wo
andere schon gesagt haben ja ja im
Sommer ist der Krieg vorbei ähm ich
komme zu meiner heutigen Einschätzung
vor allem aufgrund der russischen
Verlustraten die ich vorhin erläutert
habe und aufgrund der Tatsache dass
dieser Technologiewechsel jetzt
tatsächlich vollzogen ist sie müssen ja
denken noch im Mai 22 haben wir darüber
diskutiert ob die Ukraine jetzt wirklich
Artillerie erhalten sollte weil
Artillerie oje das ist ja nicht wirklich
eine Verteidigungswaffe ist das nicht
viel zu aggressiv auf dem Niveau waren
wir im Mai 22 ja und damals hat auch
noch niemand über Panzer gesprochen wir
erinnern uns noch am 20 Januar in
Ramstein ja stellt sich Pistorius hin
und sagt ja so Panzer gibt es jetzt
erstmal nicht und jetzt gibt's erstmal
Prüfauftrag und so ja so ähm von dem
Niveau kommen wir ähm und ähm sie sehen
was jetzt passiert im Kriegsverlauf oder
wozu die Ukraine in der Lage ist wenn
jetzt endlich mal die Waffenlieferungen
einsetzen ich persönlich bin der Ansicht
der Krieg könnte längst vorbei sein wenn
man bereits im Jahr 22 entschlossener
gehandelt hätte der Krieg hätte
vielleicht gar nicht angefangen wenn man
20 14 schon entschlossen Grenzen gesetzt
hätte aber gut
man man darf jetzt nicht über
verschüttete Milch spekulieren aber
trotzdem muss man auch ganz klar sehen
die Deutschen sind nun mal Berufs- ich
führe in Deutschland Diskussionen die
ich in Polen Baltikum oder England so
nicht führe und noch nie geführt habe
also sie sollten sich auch im Klaren
sein dass es in Deutschland immer eine
sehr spezielle und sehr pessimistische
Diskussion ist wo Optimisten automatisch
als unseriös Geld und schauen wir jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft
also auf das was jetzt kommen könnte
sogenannte Winteroffensive jetzt quasi
vorbei wir können auch nicht mehr von
Winter sprechen also jetzt geht es ja um
eine Frühjahrsoffensive und hierzu gibt
es auch Fragen im Stream also zum einen
hier da hatte ich eine gesehen es kommen
so viele jetzt muss ich kurz noch mal
schauen dass die mir nicht weg geht so
ähm hier genau also eine Frage kommt von
El Serrado bei youtube ist mit einem
ähnlichen Zusammenbruch der russischen
Linie wie im Vorjahr zu rechnen wenn die
ukrainische Offensive staatet hier wird
also auf eine Frühjahrsoffensive Bezug
genommen die Frage bezieht sich auf
Moral Ausrüstung Motivation etc ja also
sie beziehen sich wahrscheinlich auf die
auf die gegen Offensive im Raum von
isomatik ja also ich ich denke die die
Ukraine wird wieder etwas ähnliches
versuchen also eine schnelle Bewegung
mit massierten Mitteln das heißt sie
wird das versuchen was den Russen nicht
gelingt nämlich die Konzentration der
Kräfte also sprich statt an
verschiedenen isolierten Punkten ihre
Kräfte zu verpulvern wird sie mit Hilfe
der westlichen Systeme wahrscheinlich
eine große Konzentration Durchführen von
Panzern und von unterstützungsfahrzeugen
und versuchen an einem bestimmten Punkt
die Front zu durchbrechen alles andere
würde militärisch eigentlich keinen Sinn
machen also der andere gesamten
Frontlinie dafür hat sie nicht die
Ressourcen aber es gibt durchaus Punkte
der Front wo die Russen sehr ausgedient
stehen wo das Gelände das auch
befürworten würde also insbesondere im
Raum zwischen der politischer und
Melitta gerade bei mir die Topper sehen
sie so seit etwa einer Woche verstärkte
partisanenaktivität es gibt immer wieder
Anschläge auf russische und auch
ukrainische Kollaborateure die dort also
den Russen zu arbeiten mit Autobomben
beispielsweise und so etwas gab es auch
bevor die die damalige Initiative im
September 22 losgehen also ich denke da
können wir etwas erwarten in diesem Raum
und die Ukraine zieht im Moment dieses
Ressourcen dafür zusammen das tut sie
übrigens schon seit dem Februar und ich
bin recht zuversichtlich dass ihr das
wieder gelingen kann sie hatten es
vorhin auch schon angesprochen es kommen
jetzt auch neue westliche Waffensysteme
jetzt erst im in diesem Krieg in Einsatz
und dazu fragt sich Joachim Lotz bei
Youtube machen unsere Panzer denn jetzt
einen Unterschied
ja natürlich machen die einen
Unterschied und ich empfehle Ihnen immer
dazu vielleicht sich ältere Videos
anzugucken also zum Beispiel aus dem
Golfkrieg 2003 wo sie zum Beispiel sehen
was der Challenger 2 anstellt mit den
damaligen irakischen T-72 oder was ein
Bradley m2 anstellt mit T-72 also sie
müssen sich wirklich klar machen das ist
ein völlig anderes technologienniveau
die westlichen Panzer haben vor allem
den Vorteil einer viel größeren
Reichweite das heißt sie können die
russischen Panzer aus der Entfernung
abschließendes also sie müssen sich das
nicht so vorstellen dass es irgendwelche
klassischen Panzerschlachten oder
panzerdueller gibt sondern es wird
eigentlich so sein dass man aus der
Entfernung schießen wird vor allem auch
dass man nachts schießen wird weil die
westlichen Panzer viel bessere
Fähigkeiten haben was die zielaufklärung
angeht also sowohl was was die
thermische Zielerfassung angeht als auch
die Laser oder die aktuelle tonisch und
das ist nun einfach völlig anderes
Niveau als also schon als t 72 aber wenn
Sie denken das Russland jetzt T64 und
T55 hier mobilisiert dann kämpft quasi
das früher 21 Jahrhundert gegen die
Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts und die das
technologisch ausgeht das können Sie
sich denken ja man muss man darf das auf
keinen Fall unterschätzen die sind
Technologie Differenz und muss das immer
aus dieser Perspektive betrachten
und wir hatten ja angesprochen sie
hatten also gesagt das sage ich nur noch
mal kurz für jeden der jetzt erst
einschaltet sie haben also in einem
Interview gesagt und auch jetzt hier
noch mal dieser Sendung sie rechnen also
mit einem ukrainischen Sieg im Oktober
darauf bezieht sich jetzt die Frage von
Thomas Paul bei Facebook der hofft
nämlich dass die russische Armee also
noch vor Oktober zusammenbricht und
fragt sich was dann passiert also nach
einem möglichen russischen Zusammenbruch
also ich musste so ein bisschen
präzisieren ich habe gesagt Russland
wird den Krieg im Oktober militärisch
verloren haben das heißt also die
Ukraine wird meiner Prognose nach im
Oktober in einer Position sein wo sie zu
der russischen Armee sagen kann also
entweder zieht ihr jetzt ab oder ihr
kapituliert oder aber die Reste von euch
die möglicherweise noch irgendwo herum
stehen die werden dann vernichtet also
für mich wird im Oktober eine Situation
antreten so wie 1944 im europäischen
Kriegstheater des Zweiten Weltkriegs
also eine Situation wo der kriegt
militärisch verloren ist und jetzt die
könnte es weitergehen oder jetzt könnte
es durchaus allein das Putin völlig
irrational ist und sagt okay ist mir
egal dann all in dann lasse ich jetzt
halt auch meine letzten Truppen
verzweifelt kämpfen und heldenhaft
untergehen ist mir egal besser
heldenhaft sterben als irgendwie diesen
Rückzug in Kauf nehmen ich glaube aber
nicht dass das passieren wird weil bevor
dieses Ergebnis eintritt wird in
Russland eine Destabilisierung des
Machtsystems einsetzen das heißt nicht
dass der Staat oder die Föderation
Russland auseinanderbricht aber putin
wird der hier ungünstige der Krieg läuft
immer stärker in Frage gestellt werden
auch natürlich gewalttätig ich könnte
mir auch vorstellen dass gerade in den
Regionen wo sehr viele Menschen
mobilisiert worden sind also vor allem
in den Regionen wo eben nicht
überwiegend ethnische Russen wohnen wie
zum Beispiel
das da die Leute sagen na gut das haben
wir eigentlich zu erwarten von dieser
russischen Zentralgewalt und das dann
ähnliche lokale Konflikte entstehen wie
zum Beispiel Tschetschenien aber gerade
dann müsste Putin eigentlich seine
Truppen zurückziehen aus der Ukraine
damit er seine Herrschaft intern
stabilisieren und konsolidieren kann und
ich denke dass das wird zu einem einen
Moment sein wo man sich ein Kriegsende
vorstellen kann also sprich Russland
wird gezwungen seine Truppen
abzuziehen oder was heißt Russland also
Putin besser gesagt äh damit er sein
Regime intern stabilisieren kann das ist
die Einschätzung von militär-experte von
Markus Kolb von der ETH Zürich vielen
Dank dass Sie sich wirklich so viel Zeit
genommen haben für all unsere Fragen
zumindest die die hier reinbringen
konnte vielen Dank an dieser Stelle
schönen Abend ihnen danke ebenso und
auch natürlich Danke an euch ich hoffe
wie gesagt so viele Fragen wie möglich
hier mit reingebracht zu haben das Thema
wird uns ja noch eine Weile beschäftigen
deswegen freue ich mich wenn ihr
natürlich auch dann wieder dabei seid
ich habe im Stream gelesen ist auch ein
User geschrieben hat irgendwie wird bald
kriegen immer gedacht dass sie schnell
vorbei sind und das ist fast nie der
Fall das haben wir jetzt auch gesehen
und gelernt seit 13 Monaten geht dieser
Krieg schon mehr als 13 Monate und wir
werden natürlich für euch auch weiter
berichten deshalb seid gerne wieder
dabei für heute jetzt erstmal danke
schönen Abend tschüss